and welcome back to the five while
you're getting ready to celebrate the
new year I just picked up a case of
zeban myself be sure to do it with Fox
News our All-American New Year
celebration kicks off right at 10 p.m
Eastern we'll have special coverage from
Coast to Coast with some of your
favorite Fox personalities including
will Kane Rachel Campos Duffy and Pete
hegskin in Nashville and will Kane is
joining us now from the Music City to
give us a taste of what's to come
tomorrow night will how are you man nice
I like the facial uh thing going on
there very very nice sexy on some level
it's nice right the Wild Horse Saloon
right here Nashville Tennessee that's
right the All-American New Year you
don't want to be anywhere else Joe but
Fox News Channel this is going to be
awesome man we have Brantley Gilbert's
going to be performing right here on the
stage another guy by the name of let me
just see if I get it right Jimmy phela
is going to work the crowd a little bit
here he's going to come and uh and do a
set and then I think he's going to turn
over the stage to Cole Hauser who you
know from yeah Yellowstone he plays rip
we're gonna have a lot of fun we're
gonna go as you mentioned we're going to
go to Times Square we're going to New
Orleans we've got Daytona Beach Florida
we've got the United States of America
covered because of course we are Fox
we're going to be headquartered right
here Nashville Tennessee all right well
you mentioned Jimmy phela and it is New
Year's Eve which means the fashion has
to be on point so I have an assignment
for Jimmy to my left here to tell you
how to dress for tomorrow night's big
party
oh I can't wait for that and you need to
know well a lot of the jackets that you
see me wear on TV do come in men's so
don't rule them out just out of hands
it's New Year's Eve it is the one night
of the year we can get a little loud and
you my friend have the ability to wear
anything you want because I looked at
the rundown and I now know where I rank
in this company in terms of importance
to the company The Rundown is like a
block will gets a foot massage Jimmy
wrestles a bear B Block hang Seth has
ribs made from Angel meat Jimmy gets
shot out of a civil war Cannon you can
wear whatever you want I'm showing up in
a hazard suit based on what I know
Katie said that you're going to be
giving me advice on fashion if that's
the case I'm going to look like the lead
singer for Whitesnake because Jimmy
dresses as though he is about to take
over an 80s rock band cover band of
course 80s cover rock band he's gonna
he's gonna have boots on as will I but
his will almost inevitably made for some
reptile skin probably not crocodile
snake so well Jimmy Jimmy will be loud
so I think he'll be loud metaphorically
and literally so what you're telling me
is here I go again on my own yeah but
he's also saying your Larry Coverdale
it's the 33 year anniversary of that
song here I go again because I just want
to feel old for all the folks watching
at home wow slightly good Lord so will
uh will there be dancing this year
all right so Lawrence first of all you
know you and I have never had a dance
competition Lawrence we've competed in
wheelchair basketball
you can imagine the taller guy in
wheelchair basketball it was Lawrence
Jones The Winner congratulations
uh but we haven't competed in dancing
which I don't want to compete with you
on um I know I have no pride no ego
involved in dancing but last year
headset then I dressed up as uh the guys
from Dumb and Dumber and did a little
line dancing I don't think it's I don't
think Lawrence is on the agenda but
here's what I think is on the agenda I
think there will be a dunk tank I
believe there's going to be a mechanical
bull that will include all three of us
Rachel Campos to help you Pete heck sets
myself and I believe Jimmy as well will
get his turn at the mechanical bull and
hey for what it's worth Lawrence you
would have had a great time I got a
little warmed up today I landed I drove
straight to the hegseth manor just
outside of town here in Nashville where
there were some brand new dirt bikes for
the kids I got on the dirt bike which I
haven't been on a two-wheeled vehicle
since I was 16.
you know how it works Lawrence like the
gas is on the throttle all right I mean
it's right here on the handlebar it ran
away from me I tried to catch it by
grabbing it tighter it only gave it more
gas I tumbled across the whole 77 acre
spread I got
brought to you by Neosporin uh will it's
Kennedy so I know some of our other
cable news competitors have forbidden
alcohol consumption during their New
Year's Eve broadcasts uh will Fox pick
up the mantle this year and will the
dump tank in fact be filled with
Everclear
[Laughter]
um I think it's Fireball
um and uh and Kennedy I don't really
know the rules on this I probably should
have been prepped ahead of time on what
I'm allowed to admit to or not yeah
um and if an executive wants to jump in
my earpiece in the next 60 seconds
we're going to have fun Kennedy we're
gonna have fun I promise you we did last
year when we would be responsible
fun-loving Americans tomorrow night as
well you're in moonshine country now
will that's right they're going to
grease up Pete hegseth and chase them
yeah exactly I just need Pete's agents
77 Acres good job not bad well we'll see
you tomorrow night man it's looking good
Jimmy one more question for you uh all I
was going to say uh is a word of advice
to everybody watching on the Nashville
set right now no one will know if we're
drunk by comparison to the people around
us everyone is hammered like from the
minute I start co-hosting the New Year's
Eve pre-show at 9pm with Emily compagno
and the great Griff Jenkins hey girl
everybody in Nashville is plastered last
year on the way to the gig a cop stopped
being on Main Street he's like do you
drink it I was like no he's like well
here you go there he handed me a
six-pack it's going to be Rowdy it's
going to be a Rowdy 9 p.m yep it starts
tomorrow night at 9 00 PM I will unveil
my first outfit of the evening
oh you're getting three I am the Vanna
White of New Year's Eve you're gonna buy
vowels you're gonna buy shots it's going
to be a wild one all right tune in what
are you gonna do more of shots or outfit
changes well you're gonna have to tune
in at 9pm to watch how about that that's
called a cheese here's another one one
more thing that's next hi everyone I'm
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now